how about uh what went on or did not go
on with the los angeles lakers today
yeah it was tough um
they had they they have they don't have
many assets we all knew that taylor
holton tucker was probably the long um
treasury asset that they had
and
nobody in his place you you can't trade
him and get somebody to replace him that
was probably going to be an upgrade that
was going to significantly help the
lakers so they were stuck in that regard
but what i was told this sources
informed me that the rockets did reach
out to the lakers
to offer john wall
for russell westbrook but they wanted
the lakers to include a first round pick
the lakers declined that and so that was
the end of that discussion right there
so as far as that goes there was really
not not much more that the lakers could
do so this team is standing pat sources
before me they're going to go into the
buyout market and see what he's done
there but it's still looking still
looking them there as far as bringing in
somebody that's going to help and
transition them into a team that we all
thought was going to be a contingency
so chris me and chris me and kenny made
a bet about uh a month ago that the
lakers are gonna win six games in a row
are you riding with me or you riding
with kenny
so kenny said they were gonna win six in
a row yes he did on national television
i'm rolling with you chuck
so early
early still early it's still early at
the midway point before you know we're
about 42 we're more than 50 games in it
yeah we got 30 games
you're a good man we appreciate you
taking time with us tonight man thank
you they got up to four though
tell draymond i said hello yeah
i thought you were we'll do that i
thought the whole time we were talking
to draymond